something is stirring in British
politics brexit has spawned two new
blissful forces two nude parties each
arguing for one side of the new divide
the brexit party for leave and change UK
four remain born out of paralysis but
their birthright is where the
similarities end for as one is coming to
dominate these European elections the
other is the ghost at the feast all up
and down the country day after day Nigel
Farage is a rally a day two or three a
day with hundreds sometimes over a
thousand attendance there's excitement
anger - what's wrong with a good
old-fashioned British compromise
something that will bring two sides
together there's not one person in this
audience would want us to be a victim of
this complete surrender it's a document
you'd sign if you surrendered in a war
does this remind you of anything
slowly but surely trumpism his style his
peculiar form of magic is arriving in
Britain in many walks of life the
business beer theatre
Viet culture a bit political campaigning
America is always a few years ahead of
us and I have spent a fair bit of time
in America yeah in the last couple of
years hope I've learned one of two
things
meanwhile the brexit party's counterpart
change UK is struggling to get noticed
we can do this we can do this they're
meeting in Birmingham draws a smaller
crowd there isn't quite the same
indignation on display the same big
personalities they're activists say they
don't need them personality-- politics
is a dangerous thing often after a while
you spray / way surface and there's no
substance to it I'm torn between the Lib
Dems and change because they're both
stronger main parties but I believe that
change your cake and real
change the way that the government is
working today and really have an impact
looking past the mistakes they've made
there's a more fundamental reason change
isn't having more success changer gay
was founded because they thought that
their respective parties have become too
extreme yet maybe in their reason for
being lies their current problem because
in this age of fire and fury it just
isn't easy for a small party focused on
reason and moderation to cut through
they're not members of big parties
aspiring for government anymore they're
supposed to be insurgents and sometimes
it feels as if they haven't quite worked
out yeah but they say that that's the
point they won't play the same game as
the populace if you're looking for a
bunch of people to be unreasonable to
ignore fact to hate on other people to
get angry go and vote for another party
but this changes best chance to break
through if they can't it's unlikely
they'll secure a second act for the
brexit party though they're storing hide
just be beginning newest good all Sky
News